et on va recevoir dans un instant
d'invités exceptionnels pour cette
première je vous le savez que je les
aime énormément
jean claude van damme sera avec nous et
on me dit d'ailleurs que jean claude van
damme arrive devant les studios est ce
que jean claude est prêt est ce que jean
claude est prêt ou pas en régie
[Applaudissements]
ils se font plaisir
la nouvelle twingo votre mandat venant à
disparaître leurs instances
internationales je suis pas mal ou le
recevoir
jean-claude voilà qui la regarde et il
arrive il va arriver dans un instant
jean claude déjean voilà bien oui aller
contre les jambes ce soir
alors on n'a pas le son est ce qu'on
peut avoir le son le vichy jean claude
van damme jean claude van damme et je
viens pour l'émission de cyril hamelin
aller car vous avez une pièce d'identité
son nom avait pas de case identité pour
des missions hull pas bon ah oui
attendez serré lien problème et je vais
trouver une solution ok mon show qu on
retrouve dans un assaut il va trois
solutions
je pense je vois se le dise il va pas
s'arranger moment rester avec une autre
[Applaudissements]
c'est
d'être avec vous dans un instant il y
aura deux villes en pense quoi ton frère
je vous le dis ne manquez pas la
prochaine pub puisque dans la pub
maintenant c'est ont fait nous mêmes les
bandes annonces pour le film de ce soir
ce soir c'est jason bourne et c'est
bouder qui s'y colle rappeur histoire et
qui vous fera la bande-annonce ce sera
donc pendant la pub n'ont pas eu ou pas
donc vous allez voir vous allez voir il
a fait jason bourne ce soir ne manquez
surtout pas mercredi
en cas de forte tension carole rousseau
et moudeyres j'en ai pleuré
voilà pendant tout le week-end là tu t
es folle vous verrez ça et même ce soir
jason bourne
il a le physique de vos idées j'imagine
magnifique merci michel lejoyeux c'est
vrai qu'il ya d'humain j'ai travaillé
cet été merci jean michel merci c'est
vrai la bouée quoi pas que vous avez un
esprit créatif diouf a laissé le faire
sont qui me va se passer le premier
c'est ça le truc mais cela se voit là
non mais moi je laime voilà je vous aime
jean-michel continuer comme ça j'adore
merci mais n'en faites pas trop quand
même parce que c'est comment savoir ce
que vous foutez de la gueule merci on va
accueillir le premier invité c'est le
parrain de cette année je voulais
absolument pas ce que c'est vrai que
j'ai fait les plus grandes rigolades
avec lui l'année dernière génique qui
pour la première il faut que la vie il
faut que j'aie une invitée chez le plus
qui fait alors j'ai tout ce qui fait
demain par exemple noura m sila et alban
ivanov
je voulais absolument aussi très vite
mais ce soir j'espère qu'il va trouver
un moyen de rentrer puisqu'ils étaient
bloqués à l'entrée et il est avec nous
c'est une star internationale
il est culte jean claude van damme est
avec tous genres
[Applaudissements]
vva
[Rires]
célibataire
[Applaudissements]
je commence à partir en cacahuète
j'en connais je crois que c'est quoi
cette ligne de folie là c'est quoi cette
classe là tu es beau gosse toi tu es
jean t-shirt écoulé mam certain que le
paquet chaque ou danton
[Applaudissements]
vous trouvez normal de t'accueillir
invités ne fait pas ses attributs
regardez là ça fait plaisir ça avait
ébahi des îles et qu'il jean claude je
voulais te dire merci d'être avec nous
parce que c'est la première et c'est
vrai que voilà j'étais avec toutes mes
équipes et je leur ai dit celui qui
voudrait pour la première fois la le
parrain des dix ans et jean cot parce
que pour moi c'est la plus grande star
qu'on accueilli et cela
jean-claude alors c'est vrai qu'on va
vous donner cinq raisons pour lesquelles
on a choisi d'accueillir jean-claude van
damme pour ses 10 ans jean claude est ce
que tu es content d'être là très content
moi je suis comme un fou
franchement dans un compte ça va tu
connaissais pas tout le monde ce cadre à
la fois que tu es venu il a vu il avait
des gens qui est qu'ils sont partis
plein gré ou pas il ya des gens qui sont
retrouvés à agathe tu connaissais pas la
garde oui c'est pas la scène avec eux
donner 1 c'est à quoi elle a changé
ah oui tu la connais c'est d'accord tu
connaissais que dis tu connaissais kelly
match guy je vous rappelle
josé la villette dungeon aidez nous
jean-claude regardez vous à vous donner
les cinq raisons pour lesquelles on a
décidé d'inviter jean todt en date ce
soir c'est là jean claude van damme ses
62 film 58 ans et 175 mille fois le mot
were prononcées chaque jour roche
oratoire mais si on ne reçoit ce soir
c'est surtout pour cinq bonnes raisons
raison numéro un jean claude van damme
et le mix parfait entre le mma et le bhl
du sport de combat oui mais de la
philosophie sur thoune a déjà deux noms
ouais enfin pour nous ça fait deux
raison numéro 2 de recevoir jean claude
ce soir c'est parce que côté souplesse
il a tout appris à baba voici l'élève et
voici le m
troisième raison pour laquelle van damme
est notre invité c'est parce qu'il a été
le premier à nous avoir alertés sur
l'écologie bien avant nicolas hulot même
s'il utilise deux camions pour se
déplacer watch cite ce mode & crafts
bouchachi
il sait nous faire prendre conscience de
la réalité heures le merlot dans 20 30
ans il rappelé quatrième raison pour
laquelle jcvd et là ce soir
il n'est pas seulement un acteur mais
aussi médecins généralistes carrément
créé toujours forte gauche la montjoie
et enfin cinquième et dernière raison
pour laquelle on reçoit jean claude ce
soir c'est parce qu'ils nous aiment et
qu'ils lèvent tout le monde j'aime bien
les belles choses j'aime bien les belles
femmes les beaux-arts où je viens à
l'est les gens qui sont intelligents on
est les jeux made men den den 1 qui ont
qui s'amenait à peindre alors au nom de
tous les nains qui savent bien peindre
bienvenue sur notre plateau jean claude
van damme
[Applaudissements]
alors jean claude toi qu un parcours
incroyable c'est vrai parce que toi donc
tu es belle est arrivé aux etats-unis
raconte-nous encore l'histoire puisque
moi j'adore quand tu raconte son
histoire parce que c'est vrai que tu
connaissais personne
et là c'est un truc de ouf qui lui est
arrivé à jean claude mais je crois qu'on
aura passé temps pour raconter
l'histoire mais en face c'était une
longue histoire et producteur
d'émissions mais ça commence avec un
rêve qui s'est donc qui se réalisait
c'était quoi ton rêve à la base mais
essaie d'être d'être connu ouais pour
deux raisons pour un peu épater les
parents toit a vu que j'étais pas
vraiment travailler vers les côtes
faisait pardon je travaillais bien
l'école j'ai quitté à 13 ans l'école
ouais c'est quand mature et j'écoutais à
présent et j'ai travaillé sur
l'intuition assez pour nous un peu tu
sais ans j'ai vendu des fleurs balawi
comme 14 dans les ristournes et occupent
aujourd'hui des bonhommes aussi qu'on
jette comme ça si vite
j'ai commencé le karaté très jeune c'est
vrai ouais c'est quoi tes titres
c'est ce que direct et un teint tuant
karaté et les mecs je pouvais lire tu as
fait quoi quand votre sport de combat tu
as fait chuter jusqu'à champion du monde
à forest national et general motors en
même temps que votre champion dominique
valéra et après tu es parti aux états
unis
oui hélas hélas j'ai clairement ses fins
la galère ce qu'on a plein air mais je
te re il avait 50 dollar en poche
ouais c'est vrai qu'à vite arrivé
combien 3000 pendant le premier
[Rires]
mais les tueries fermés dans l'autre
sens
il avait 50 dollars non j'avais 50
mineurs sa tête avait 3000 $ en poche
qui part avec 3000 $ est arrivé aux
etats-unis
voilà et donc là le rêve se réalise très
vite et c'était pas facile bon il
fallait donc parler l'anglais je tenais
tellement bons en anglais mais j'avais
reçu donc à visa donc à l'époque c'est
un visa de six mois ouais donc c'était
aller retour mexico mexico los angeles
et j'ai parlé à l'étape producteurs des
gens jiminez photo / j'ai suivi des gens
jettent un peu partout quoi
et ouais après et après il a une
histoire incroyable ça devenu une star
internationale
alors où j'ai envie d'avoir ton avis sur
plein de sujets ce que tu donnes ton
avis sur tout je vais te montrer des
choses tu me donnes ton est moins les
réseaux sociaux par exemple les réseaux
sociaux tu en penses quoi
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent des réseaux
sociaux a je crois que c'est super tu
aimes bien ouais t'es sûr orsenna vert
thé sur un stade soit sur un instant
ouais j'ai instagram ouais d'accord mais
je ne fais pas de la star
je suis un chagrin mais c'est quelqu'un
qui se creuse à bonbons d'accord très
bien tu fait transpirer là que tu poses
de l'amour ou d'affection et d'amour
sinon il fera chaud ses émotions
non je te fasse un bisou non serre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non parce qu'en fait c'est que eric
naulleau et qu'elle suppose de l'amour
l'amour ce bon amour ce bien tamurt en
ce moment ah ah non pas trop mon patron
d'accor a trop à ça un peu bien sûr
voilà le cri du public de la vie coûté
la vie à wemmel amour de la vie ouais
bah l'amour la ville où couach dessous
voilà que tu penses des vegan day des
velan vegan assez bien c'est bien mais
être trop mégane s'est pas trop voyant
enfin il faut quand même équilibré enfin
pas trop quand on va manquer d'en face
sur seront sûrement astro ne se mange
pas de sueur mange que des légumes on ne
va pas c'est d'amener un site
il faut quand même d'accord une certaine
base de manas sid pour un accord ouais
c'est un record et et qu'il suppose de
ses six nominés comment il en français
c'est bien sûr si laminé je vois d'ici
plus chaudes ou fait ça va tu es content
d'être ici en blanc mais j'ai mis de la
crème avant de make up
mais qui crée des hydratants devrait pas
aller me le demander mais j'ai mis de la
crème de la scène c'est un truc pas cher
alors jean-claude on dirait pas mais tu
devrais chaux-de-fonds avec taiwan est
alors lui la jeunesse ou jamais chose
c'est quoi ton secret il est tellement
chaud ici avec ce qu'il boit que là il
est complètement maîtrisé ray
françois-ier mépris l'on trouve à ta
passion était contente d'un jean claude
van damme
ah ça fait plaisir mais tu l'avais déjà
vu ou pas mais oui on s'était croisé pas
mal deux fois en fait les croisés sur
ces 8 mai ici là sur scène bah ouais
ouais ouais ouais non mais faut pas être
ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il faut pas il
faudrait essayer de ne pas dépasser son
niveau réel le niveau réel que l'on a
[Rires]
c'est bien c'est vrai c'est à dire
pourquoi parce qu'ensuite la fée des
questionnements auxquels on pourra
jamais avoir de réponse oui je pense
qu'il faut que vous discutez tous les
deux justement on va lancer deux buts
les deux minutes avec doc gynéco c'est
bien voir le docteur c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
alors jean claude tu avais discuté déjà
avec doc gynéco à l'époque quand tu
étais venu sur le prime et pour des
raisons de timing la séquence a duré que
2 fois 2 minutes cette fois ci on va
lancer deux minutes jean-claude on sait
que tu as une passion telle passion pour
les chiens adore les chiens est vrai
tant adoptent régulièrement ça c'est
bravo d'ailleurs joué à dire bravo pour
ce que tu fais pas ce qu'il fait plein
de trucs pour son aise devant des
associations et tu fais un truc
formidable pour les animaux donc bravo
mon jean claude et j'aimerais que vous
parliez des chiens tous les deux pendant
des minutes c'est la minute gynéco c'est
parti on y va védrine bas j'ai une fois
un pitbull
je les laissais dans la voiture on a
cassé la vitre on me l'a volé c'était
une femelle en plus j'adore
naret ouais ouais c'est un mélange donc
je crois qu'ils ont fait un mélange de
tu sais que je suis champion de jeu
jouit de champion de ju jitsu non mais
parfois c'est il faisait chaud là bas où
tu étais avec ton chien ils l'ont bien
j'étais au studio jédir ces essais dans
la bagnole mes marques
parce qu'ils ont autorisations aux états
unis que s'il fait trop chaud tu vois et
des chiens qui peuvent mourir n'a bien
sûr qu'à ses enfants la pauvreté lé mans
avait des trucs à faire
non j'avais conscience que je l'avais
laissée dans la voiture
la volée et je crois que c'est un
mélange de plusieurs spermatozoïdes de
chiens bull ouais ouais ouais mais aussi
dans les différents styles de chiens
quand j'étais plus jeune les vieilles
dames à decani plus vu disparu les
caniches
ouais ouais après le berger allemand
gens voient plus du sport le pitbull est
arrivé disparu ah ouais
ta problème avec les chiens quand elle
ne sait plus qui reste qu'est ce que
vous en faites de tous les autres chiens
qui disparaît non mais c'est vrai que
les chiens les piles où l'on est et
c'est une race qui était un peu pas
transformer métamorphoser pour pour les
combats et tout mais c'est ça dépend du
maître tu sais les chiens cdc des
animaux qui sont tout à fait fidèles qui
sont ça au fond les chiens nous ont été
données pour apprendre l'amitié la
sincérité
j'adore les chiens c'est pour ça aussi
mais pourquoi est ce que tu dirais que
quelqu'un préfère son chien à l'être
humain parce que non l'être humain je
les aime bien mais le chien c'est tout à
fait c'est quelque chose qui est tout à
fait amour inconditionné qui fait
[Applaudissements]
bravo à jean claude poursuivre ce qui
fait pour pour les animaux jean claude
tu sais qu'on a préparé l'émission et
moyennes séquences vraiment culte avec
toi dans un film c'est tu as inventé la
danse du kuduro
c'est vrai c'est rare danse du kuduro
c'était en 96 ouais c'est dans kick
boxeur ouais quand tu danses
il ya une scène au personnage de jean
claude et soupe et ils dansent dans un
bar tu danses vraiment il est sexy de
ouf
regarde regarde
[Musique]
hamon
l'as monaco
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je parais gens tout à fait des cours de
danse ou quoi sans rigoler oui j'ai fait
de la danse classique sais pas mais ça
nous amène dans ce set tu danses comment
ou alors c'est parce que justement voilà
qu'elle y est ce que vous voulez faire
une qui est démonstration avec jean
claude a passé le chercher lecture merci
et j'en oublie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai vu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
kelly brown
est ce que tu veux faire un différend
avec alibaba les films et je serais pas
du tout à base et fais toi mais les
mamies chorale en mamie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]